[Music]
[Applause]
and i uh look up and there he is brian
windhorst the espn senior nba writer
thanks for joining us brian i mentioned
that you said everything will be on the
table for the lakers this offseason that
includes anthony davis what leads you to
believe that
i just i don't dan i don't know what
they're going to do i i i'm looking at
with the cards that they're holding
i
i just don't know how they dramatically
get out of this situation and so
i think they'll discuss it do i think
they'll do it
i don't know i don't see a trade that
makes sense uh for them right now also i
don't know if i would trade a guy who's
a top 15 player when he's healthy
because it's so hard to get that and i
don't think you're going to get that in
return so ultimately i don't think they
will but i'm just looking at what they
have to do like again i honestly think
that
they're going to have to call the other
29 teams and they're going to have to
say
what can you send us russell westbrook
you know not as a player forget about
him as a player just as a 47 million
dollar expiring contract we will gather
the contracts you don't want on your
books anymore and we'll take them we'll
take three
nba players whoever they are and you can
use russell westbrook to
sell tickets to
rebuild your salary cap to
release
and we will take any three players i
mean i honestly think that's where
they're gonna have to start and i still
don't know if they're gonna get takers
or somebody that doesn't say yeah we'll
take them but send us your unprotected
2027 first round tech i just think it's
gonna be really hard
it sounds hopeless
well it's not helpless if you have
lebron and a.d i mean just to be clear
but they're both healthy and playing
they're really good but
dan when they won the title in the
bubble they were the number one
defensive team there in orlando and last
year they were remember they were in
really good position before lebron
sprained his ankle it was a really bad
injury and it derailed them but
for the season they were
the number one defensive team number one
so
they had good bones if you will and so
when they train it for russell westbrook
a lot of people focus on
oh it was just a terrible fit with
lebron and that's true of course
but to get russell westbrook they traded
away
the core
of their defense
kentavious caldwell pope
and kyle kuzma were really valuable
defensive players and the guys they
replaced them with were not and so
they've gone from number one defense i
didn't check it this morning but like
they've been down around 20.
that's a catastrophic
fall when their team was built on doing
that
and so
that is the issue how do you recapture
that when you've already gassed all of
your resources to get a player that is
not working and i know you brought this
up that lebron works in four-year
increments whether it's cleveland miami
cleveland now with los angeles
well i don't think he can work in a
four-year increment now in l.a is is he
there for the rest of his career
i don't think he's going anywhere i
don't think he wants to go anywhere um
you know i was looking so the lakers
team is the oldest team
in the nba and so i i wanted to know the
oldest team since went
and i had somebody here at espn go
research it for me and he said it's the
oldest team since the 2010 cavs
and i was not surprised at all and by
the way that doesn't even include the
2014 miami heat where when they lost
that finals to the spurs i went into the
locker room shane battier announced his
retirement in the locker room ray allen
basically brought the ball to the
one-yard line on retiring and richard
lewis who
started the game that night never played
in the nba again so three of the
three you know three of the starters
three of the top six players from his
last year in miami never played again so
this is what happens when you have
lebron you pour yourself in you trade
your draft picks you sign veterans you
do everything you can and a franchise
just can't do that
over and over and over and two years ago
i would have told you oh they have a.d
who's in his mid-20s and in his prime
maybe that won't happen now maybe the
window will extend maybe they've learned
from watching what happened with the
cavs and then the heat and then the cavs
again because by the way cavs 2018
they're relying on you know kyle korver
and jeff green and stuff like that
and then they do the westbrook trade
they sign you know five guys in their
mid to late 30s and we are in the exact
same spot and
when lebron left the heat they were
lucky that they still had dwayne wade
but when lebron left the cavs the first
time they were awful lebron left the
cavs the second time they were awful the
lakers if lebron were to leave right now
would be
you know non-playoff team that's what
being with lebron for a year on a year
out does
if you look back and i know you know the
benefit of hindsight there why couldn't
lebron make it work with the younger
players that he had that that nucleus is
still a pretty good nucleus and even in
you know good players on other teams
why was he not willing to make that work
well first off lebron has never valued
draft picks or playing with young
players if you go look at his career
he's only
played with a handful of first-round
picks um because most of them have been
traded and i always remember when he
came back to cleveland you know when he
he wrote his you know letter and he was
like yeah i'm looking forward to playing
with these guys and he didn't mention
andrew wiggins who had just been drafted
with the number one overall pick like 15
minutes beforehand he was like bye bye
andrew i'm interested in kevin love
and so part of it is the teams he's
playing with reacting to him and so
one of the young players he's actually
played with in the last couple years is
taylon horton tucker was one of the few
guys who had been a draft deck he's
taken along like daniel gibson taylor
horton tucker
norris cole like this is the list dan
that's the list
it's never been something he's valued
like when we saw what he did um when he
when he retweeted les snead who traded
all those picks and you know the the
parade in l.a he wore that shirt it said
f them picks
lebron tweeted that and he goes legend i
think he said legend with multiple
exclamation points lebron's like get me
one of those shirts like that's the way
lebron feels so it's hard to stay young
when you perpetually are wanting
your peers and lebron's pure age is
going up and up and up to be with you on
the team
brian windhorst espn senior nba writer
is your answer different if i say who
should win mvp and who will win mvp
well i've
pretty consistently voted in our straw
polls for embiid i think he's been
amazing i think he plays at both ends of
the court
um i think the things that he does i
mean like people talk about nikola
yokocho what he does for the nuggets
offense and of course in fact earlier
this year dan i you know most of the
media doesn't sit on the floor anymore
they've sold those seats they've moved
us off i've got gray hair now when all
my hair was brown i sat on the court you
should probably have sat on the court
many times i sat in a game in oklahoma
city and i sat in the like the second or
third row so i was basically eye level
with jokic and i could kind of see what
he sees that he sees and it my
admiration went even higher because i
could see actually how great his reads
were in real time at his eye level
i won't take anything away from him but
if you watch embiid
he does a lot for the sixers offense he
comes out in the high pick and roll he
sets things up he plays inside he plays
outside
i
believe he still to this moment has my
mvp vote but our straw poll that tim
bontemps on our staff did and this i
can't emphasize this enough and i
noticed that caesar's moved their odds
after this poll came out because caesars
has watched this poll
this is a poll
of
100 likely mvp voters there's only 100
and when tim does this poll he doesn't
call 25 people in new york and 25 people
in los angeles he calls people in every
nba city he talks to people in italy he
talks to people in in outside the
country who because those guys get mvp
votes he talks to broadcast you talk to
radio people he talks to tv to to
writers it's a real pull of how the
voters are feeling that came out
yesterday and that poll says jokic is in
the lead it's it's not a huge margin but
he is in the lead and the odds
immediately started flipping and they
were right because you could make a case
stand for somebody else and i could
listen to it and agree with you this is
where the voters are thinking today that
it's jokic
having voted on it for many many years
it always felt like we were looking for
a new story when carl malone charles
barkley and i kept voting for jordan and
then you know media members in the in
phoenix in salt lake would be critical
of me and i go i just know what i know
and i know what i see
mike's the most valuable player
i i was watching giannis last night
against embiid i think giannis is
competing with himself
and we take him for granted like he's
gotten to the point where we take him
for granted which isn't fair to him and
we've told that story and i said i
thought embiid was going to win it or at
least the last couple of months because
we haven't told that story i don't know
how much that factors into this brian
we've told the joke you know jokic story
this is the one that it feels like all
right joel embiid is next it's like the
um the actor who hasn't won the academy
award okay now it's your turn
that's exactly right well i'll just
bring up the classic case of this
westbrook
you know there hadn't been an mvp who
hadn't had been on the 50-win team in
something like 25 years it was like
moses malone i can't remember if it was
what the i think was with the rockets in
the early 80s
typically the mvp came off one of the
three or four best teams in the league
but that year with westbrook
we were all into that story of the get
back season on durant and then he put
the cherry on top with the triple
doubles and i remember this game that he
played in denver right about this time
maybe a little bit later early april
it was the night he he guaranteed
himself i think the triple double he
knew he was going to get it
to the average a triple-double and he
hit like a
25-footer at the buzzer to win the game
and eliminate the nuggets from playoff
contention i'm going to underline that
he eliminated the nuggets from playoff
contention in denver
and the crowd in denver gave him a
standing ovation
not a good sign for the nuggets faithful
but was an indication of how much those
fans loved the story
they loved the story of westbrook
getting back at durant by doing this and
in a situation like that the story
carried the day so they finished like
the sixth or seventh seed
and he won the mvp so that's definitely
a case the other thing is you're right
giannis isn't contending against embiid
and jokic he's contending against
himself from previous years when he won
his second mvp a couple years ago he won
defensive player of the year
and mvp it's one of the great seasons
we've seen in the modern era i voted for
lebron i think seven years in a row
between 2000 maybe nine and two thousand
about 1516.
he won four of them
i would argue that some of those years
he was still the best player but
the first year in miami the story wasn't
great first year back in cleveland they
were 19 and 20 coming out of the gates
it's it is everything that you said i
couldn't have said better myself
how good is lebron's son
um he's very good uh
he's going to be uh i don't know if he's
gonna go play in college if he were to
go play in college he would probably get
a high major offer
whether he would be a
star on that team i don't know um having
seen him play
he is in tremendous physical condition
he is in better condition than his dad
was at the same age because
his dad never lifted a weight in his
life he was 16. this kid was having
personal training i don't know when he
was 10. so he's done incredible work on
his physique he's very
very conditioned but he is not the
athlete lebron was lebron was six foot
seven six foot eight
240 pounds when he was 17. he came into
the nba
he was one of the few 18 year olds ever
who physically wasn't intimidated the
only player that intimidated lebron as a
rookie was ron artest he was the only
guy who could get into lebron
that would not be the case for most 18
year olds so
ronnie is very skilled i talked to
i think he's listed as a four-star
prospect so think about that a four-star
prospect that's what
kentucky north carolina used to go after
he would be able to play a school like
that how many four-star prospects make
the nba
i don't know what the percentage is but
it's not super duper high
obviously if he wants to be in the nba
he'll get a chance in the nba that will
be the his last name will carry him as
to that but
i think assuming that he's going to be
ready at age 19
that's a big ass dan maybe he will be i
mean that's two years from now maybe he
will be but when i saw him play
he was a freshman and there were two
guys on his
team that year that are now in the nba
zaire williams who put the grizzlies
and brandon boston with the clippers
those guys when you saw them you were
like
whoa
i will see that gentleman in the nba in
two years
i don't get that same vibe and my people
i talk to don't get that same vibe about
brownie there are actually people and
i've never seen his younger son bryce
play
there are people who have told me that
bryce actually might be the better
prospect amongst the two but his but
bryce i think is
13 or something like that i don't i
don't know if we can go that far down
the list i remember watching when lonzo
ball was playing and l'angelo and
lamello
and i'm watching and i think he was a
freshman at the time lamelo and i said
that's the guy who i think is going to
be the best player
but he didn't know how to play like he
was just all over the place and they you
know they all they did is run and gun
lonzo loved his passing l'angelo could
shoot i thought lumello
had the entire game i didn't know that
he would be this good but you know you
start to see guys in the embryonic
stages and then you you know that that's
what they're always trying to project
it's really hard to do and i that's why
when somebody says can bronie play in
the nba and i'm like i don't know i've
watched him play and there are times
when he's on the floor and i don't know
he's on the floor when lamelo was on the
floor i knew that he was on the floor he
was involved in everything
yes and i mean i i don't think it's a
matter i mean i don't think it's a
matter of comparing him to lebron
because lebron was the greatest high
school player that people who'd watched
high school basketball for 50 years have
ever seen
but
i would argue that it's i don't know if
he's
making the best decision about
putting a pressure on ronnie maybe he is
i mean maybe this is
he thinks he's going to react with
pressure but when you go out and say
i really can't wait to play with my son
because you know when lebron was coming
of age
ken griffey and ken griffey jr were were
doing that and ken griffey jr was a mega
star in the world of sports when lebron
was
13 14 15 years old the guy at um
ned nike who was made like lebron's
father figure lynn merritt before he
handled lebron for nike he handled ken
griffey jr lebron's first game as a cav
in the nike seats phil knight
lynn merritt
ken griffey jr
and world wide west but um ken griffey
jr came to his first game so i think he
had this affinity for that
for decades now
it's it's a lot to ask
from the young man and i will say this i
spent time at sierra canyon where he
plays in the san fernando valley
dan i couldn't be more impressed
with them with a high school basketball
program and the thing that i love about
it is that there's no
they're not pretending what they're
doing they know exactly what they're
doing they're trying to prepare
professional athletes
he couldn't be in a better place i'm
sure it's one of the reasons why lebron
sent you know moved out to la
he's getting every advantage possible
and one of the things is they don't let
ronnie do interviews like when i went to
see him play wasn't allowed to interview
him so i thought oh that's really good
and then i saw that there was a camera
crew following him around he's putting
all the way out to his car
to get into his this is a 14 or 15 year
old freshman all the way out to his car
to get into his car and the camera crew
was from lebron's company so i was like
you know i was like i don't know are we
protecting him are we not and you know i
don't have a star 17 year old son what
do i know i'm not an nba superstar i
don't know but i i i worry that his
experience is not going to be maybe what
it could be
it's always great to catch up with you
thanks for joining us brian thanks for
having me dan have a good day that's
brian windhorst espn senior nba writer